I must warn you I will not Le a second
in
command I will win by
fire I destined for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it at top my own
head so um
1977 yeah you made the dualist yes if
somebody had sort of sent back a little
time capsule with a lits or waterl or a
scene from this film would you have
believed it yes really yeah how so I
mean well you know julus explored with
Joseph conrro yeah hey he was doing aund
it was a 100 page book Nolla was going
to be his big sketch for war in
peace but what I loved was the obsession
of the class Obsession there's upper
class and there was the lower class two
officers they were dual and at the end
of it one of them would forget the
original reason for the duel which is to
me a great metaphor for the craziness of
violence and War but the film ends
on the character who's obsessed by
Napoleon everything he stands for it's
Harvey K tell's character pharoh he
stands on a cliff and
fundamentally has to settle for his lot
at this point in the story and I also
thought that's the image of Napoleon
bonapar I RIT the film about 3 years ago
and watched it thought damn it's a good
movie it is a really good movie and it
won an award so congratulations yeah all
these years
later it it re resurrect the idea what I
do Napoleon have a go oh okay well I I
read that you actually studied a lot of
paintings to sort of inform yourself who
he was what the time was like and when I
watch this film I wrote down holy sh
this movie is amazing it looks incred
incredible it feels like a painting from
that time it almost feels like it's lit
like paintings from that time so if you
can talk about how those paintings
informed who Napoleon was and the time
for you that we see in this film well
you know the penes the appeared were
very
literal so they almost like played
camera photographs so when you're
looking at the penny you're looking at a
time warp those pennies are time warps
so you look in the corner the P see the
furniture the people Street SC you can
look at the street scen so it's I don't
know who said somebody said there's a
picture worth a thousand
words and and I used to think it was was
a Hollywood director it wasn't it was
ibson can you believe that Ipson um said
that in so many words so but a picture
is with in we do deal with Cinema so I
look at images as my research I don't
read that much I'm very visual too yes I
love a good visual Ridley um let's talk
about your two Powerhouse leads I also
it's my understanding that you watched
some improv between the two of them and
you were blown away yes so I'm wondering
like either if you can recall a specific
moment cuz I feel like they were
hilarious and I know you always look to
humor in films I didn't think this was
going to be that me it's meant to be
funny yeah but I didn't think Napoleon
was going be fun in letter said does it
mean that Napoleon is actually a bad
lover missed the point dude so no it's
thank God yes it's meant to be fun
exactly because isn't the bedroom
frequently funny it could can be well
it's also when you meet somebody there's
a flirty nature to were you're playing
with each other more than that I think
she was less impressed by him than he
was by her so if you like she tolerated
his attention yeah initially yeah then I
think it changed to uh affection respect
did she love him um don't think so but
great friendship yes
that's tanam out to a relationship I'm
wondering I know you've often shot with
sixday cameras you're very efficient
you're a great strategist and you love
France this sounds like Napoleon you
couldn't even compare you know people AR
aware of this but there's two and a half
thousand books written on Napoleon
bonapart I can't think of any leader
politician King you name it has been so
covered what is there about in the
people fascinated by but he's still en
enigmatic exactly there's no real answer
yeah do you feel like you have the
answer now cu no I think the story the
way I've done it is multifaceted
multicolors and but I think they said
was he did she influence him in his
strategy I don't think so at all I think
those his world and career and armies
and victories and and disasters and then
it his private life which is her MH so
when he was in Egypt Egypt he left Egypt
and left his army there because he
thinks she was playing around in Paris
unbelievable sounds like 2023 sir
yes um you often shoot with like I said
multiple cameras up to 11 in some of
these battle scenes yeah you got to know
where to put them though and the the
attention to detail if you could maybe
just break down a little bit of aets
because some of that underwater stuff I
know mechanical horse maybe you created
that water like tank tank yeah tank were
you absolutely it to get those things on
filming what kind of Joy did that bring
you to see it come together well you
know it's like a
child great quote by Austin well said
film making is the best toy train set a
boy could ever have and that's fun
making films is is huge pressure you got
to embrace stress but with whatever you
think you feel you're really living what
kind of you're caus under pressure what
kind of conversations cuz I know W is
you you sang his praises the attention
to detail and the conversations that you
had prior to filming where he felt like
he didn't know if he had it what were
some of those conversations like I want
to leave I don't want to do it really I
mean what with 3 weeks
out I'm ring I'm going no but I went to
that on on Gladiator so I'd been there
before I think it's his way I think he
is so
insecure which actually is his
fuel Black's insecurity is his fuel yeah
some people work better that way under
the under pressure yeah but it's real I
don't think it's it's not something he
just adapts or adopts it is really
insecure speaking of gladiator your knee
deep back in it yeah what kind of
Russell was obviously so iconic so
iconic mhm what kind of energy does Paul
bring in this modern telling and and
what sort of
what sort of tone will the film have
will it be reminiscent and is has it
been nostalgic for you no I don't get
nostalgic yes I bet you do I think uh
Russell was quite different kind of
character and of course everyone knows
that it's not a secret what the story is
the character that now I'm not going to
tell you the story I'll answer in
abstract Paul um is playing a
character it's very difficult it's out
there he's playing Lucius tell me
something that's not out there not out
there well he's playing Lucius they came
out early on said what um and therefore
he's been in the wilderness for let's
see last time when he was
12 when now it say I don't know it's
about 12 15 years later he's been out in
the wilderness
having lost connect touch with his
mother mother lost touch with him she
doesn't know where he is she thinks he
might be dead that's the story um real
quick wae as much as you do these epic
scale films what I love is your
attention to detail the fact that he
cuts himself shaving and I didn't know
if that was real but oh you had to cut
we have to get the cut yeah yeah but I
didn't know if that actually happened if
he actually maybe it actually like cut
put but um the attention to detail can
you talk about as a director when you
see Walken in a close-up because when I
was watching it his close-ups I don't
know if there's anybody better mhm as a
director and when you're sitting behind
the lens what you you you've talked
about how he's the most sympathetic
character in Gladiator yeah yeah he very
to me in Gladiator very he was a product
of a delinquent father father didn't see
him for 17 years then he comes and said
you're not going to be the prince of
Rome that's a killer so and there's
nothing to be said there's no
connection and therefore he makes a plea
that I have the I I have you know I have
good points uh so that was tragic to me
and what was your question well be you
really wanted to cast him in Napoleon
and apparently he didn't think he was
right for the role so what did you see
in him face that's what I'm saying he
looks like he looks like Neo but his but
his inner stuff his inner stuff is
incredible oh no there's a um he'll
laugh I said there's a there's a dark
side to what him but there's also a
great comical side to him so you got a
massive you've got a huge choice between
those two coms I led Defence victory at
too
long what is your name Napoleon as the
course of my life just changed Napoleon
first of all we were just I was just
chat chatting with Walken and I'm so
curious about this sense of play between
the two of you because the thing that I
loved most about this film that it was
not
expecting was that these this felt like
a real relationship this didn't feel
like one of those Hollywood scripts
where it's like everything's all good or
all bad it was incredibly complex and I
understand that you guys sort of like
brought surprises to set like The
Crawling under the table and the oinking
and all that so if you can talk a little
bit about how you surprised him or how
he surprised you yeah I think that's so
true isn't it it was their relationship
is so inherently surprising I mean we
were continually eluded by the nature of
what it was and how different it was in
different phases of their life and we
always used to say isn't it interesting
it's not a graph of growing love and
growing content and you know less drama
it was kind of like this and that was
really challenging to play Because when
you're playing the ark over many years
and you think about what's happening in
the ex external life publicly it's so
dramatic it's so extreme when you're
trying to think of as if and you know as
if in my life it would be like it's it
was so hard because the nature of the
extremity of the time that they were
living and what those two people were
living through and and doing together
and apart and watching him do what he
went on to do it was just um yeah
elusive Beyond and so we had to try and
make the commitment to going okay I
found her to be extremely enigmatic and
um ephemeral and how can
we do something strange and
unusual in this rather than a kind of
sweeping love story where as you say
everything's um clear so unclear that's
it's so funny that you said that because
I was thinking to put yourself can you
imagine the enormity like we go to we
come to Paris and we visit these Gardens
and homes and castles and this is this
was where she lived do you feel like she
felt like at the time cuz right now the
world feels smaller I feel because we
have so much connection do you feel like
she had a sense of the enormity of it
all like the fact that hundreds of years
later were visiting these places but
that was her real life I don't know you
know it's interesting isn't it because
the vastness of it even the land and the
Empire that he was going off to conquer
and she built this house that was her
little sanctuary in the end um and where
she died and where she lived out the
last days of her life without him and it
was incredibly traumatic and painful and
but it was her sort of safe calm place
and I spent a lot of time there and her
tomb is sort of near in a little a
little church nearby m's on her house
but she imported all these exotic
animals from Australia so I think she
had the the understanding of the the
enormity of what they were doing but
personally the inner struggles that I
think she had and the amount she had to
repress and contain and the amount of
domestic conflict that was happening
between them and Obsession and um
infantilizing and acquiescing and need
Independence was
just probably the most immediate
um concern I would say from what I read
in her life more than
the than the action of what was
happening yeah while Keen talked about
cuz I asked him about the meat cute
between the two of them and he said you
guys really worked on getting that right
and you sort of reworked it he spoke to
the writer but you immediately have that
power Dynamic and it shifts throughout
the movie like in one scene I'm like
okay now he has the upper hand because
she kind of needs him financially or
have that place but then emotionally he
was almost like a like a adolescent who
has his first girlfriend according to
him so yeah about talk about sort of
that initial scene getting that cuz
you're a Powerhouse like every role you
do you're are just incredible and the
amount of power the second he sort of
buckles to her I'm like okay this is
incredible I think it's yeah there's
something adolescent in both of them
them I think which is why we wanted
their meeting to be strange and
unconventional and not um we also wanted
to answer the question which I don't I
don't think we did of why it was
Josephine to him his whole life and for
him to finish his life to end his life
and and to have the last word be
Josephine you know he was obsessed from
the minute he met
her and it's always so kind of
unanswered as why her why was it her you
know in the end he it was only because
you couldn't have children which just
must have been beyond devastating for
her I think to to feel that pressure of
an Empire on your body and not be a not
it not perform in the way that it's
being expected I I couldn't imagine the
pain of that for her but um with the
meeting we wanted there to be this
something about her that was so
unknowable that he spent his whole life
trying to grab it and hold on to it and
therefore the power had to had to switch
when she wasn't fully his and she was
having Affairs and affair with a
23-year-old and it was hippolite it was
very well documented a lot of people saw
it taking place while he was away and
for him to throw her out and to be
begging for her survival really to be
there and have to um all those parts of
you that she was expressing kind of
repress them in order to coexist um and
and maintain it and then become Empress
you know she was no way wanted to give
that up but in order to to make that
happen it wasn't like she could go and
get a quiet life and live in the rural
lands and have a blissful time she was
she was in the middle of the heart of
this Empire and this you know brutality
and to me I thought the only only nature
of Personality that could do that would
be someone so resilient that had so much
um apparent dignity but inside be so um
committed to it and therefore would
sacrifice parts of herself in order to
to be there and so there was was an enig
enigmatic quality to her that I found
really hard to try and get inside cuz I
don't feel like I'm like that at all I
feel like it's really clear how I feel
about things probably way too clear um
but this was someone that had to you
know push it all down and I think in a
way I I felt like that was maybe why he
was so obsessed with her cuz I I
couldn't I couldn't think why with all
their dramas and all their all the
dysfunction why it would have carried on
I didn't know why she was so much to how
why he felt the way about her until I
watched the film and I knew it I I could
see why what do you think it was he
could never really have her heart fully
I think she he loved her more than she
loved him sometimes for a man that's
difficult especially a man in his
position but I feel like it was your
performance it was sort of her charm and
the fact that she always kind of had him
like he never fully had her so maybe she
was a better strategist than he was in a
sense he's always been called a great
must did you read the letters yes my you
did they're so amazing H they're so
fascinating have you have you read any
I've read a few of them but Ridley said
that it's almost embarrassing some of
the things that you wrote it is is it
yeah how did it
inform who she was to you I think
because again it was this potency that
she had inherently that he must have
been he just wanted it somehow and it
wasn't again
something I think there there was other
people throughout his life you know
other women who' been presented Ed very
young by different you know um people in
power and their daughters and it was
very so much that time for women which I
just I can't imagine how hard that would
be to be presented like that and there
were so many and because they all wanted
it and needed it he wasn't I it didn't
feel like he was that attracted but as
you said because she had a um
withholding from him all the way through
even in the second half when she becomes
quite young and quite so vulnerable it's
almost like like it was so strange
playing it because it was a the
frightened little girl inside came out
so she became it's so it's it was funny
in moments to feel that very vulnerable
young part of her be out in the second
half much more than the first half when
she didn't you know she wasn't um
needing anyone but I think it was
probably
his so to answer your question the
letters
seem like this mad expression of in M
you know crazy infactuation a wildness
for somebody who he couldn't
contain um or
own and then it's it gets very
dysfunctional when he tries to because
she becomes a prisoner I think in
his in his
Mania